okay perfect
hi everyone my name is nikon and today
i'll be talking about continuous lwe
and our results that continuous lwe is
as hard as lwe
this is joint work with uh parna and my
advisor vinod at mit
so the brief outline of what i'll talk
about today
i'll talk very briefly about learning
with aries i'm sure most of us are
familiar with
i'll talk about a continuous analog that
was recently defined
called continuous learning with errors
or clwe
they'll talk about some of the
applications of clwe and why the problem
is interesting
lastly i'll talk about our results
reducing lwe to clwe and i'll mention
some of the applications
okay so lwe is something i'm sure many
of you are familiar with so i'll go
pretty quickly but if anything's
confusing of course feel free to stop me
so let z sub q denote integers mod q
n of mu sigma squared will denote the
univariate gaussian distribution with
mean mu
and standard deviation
sigma decisional lwe assumption
says that if we have a secret vector s
uniformly randomly drawn from c q to the
n
and we take let's say m samples
or we have each ai drawn uniformly at
random from z q to the n
and we have noise e i from a univariate
gaussian
with mean zero and standard deviation
sigma
we have that the samples ai along with
noisy inner products of ai with the
fixed secret s
taken mod q
should be indistinguishable from a i
along with uniformly random real numbers
between 0 and q
so just one way to formulate the
standard decisional lwb assumption
okay so you know why care about lwe
certainly many reasons
one reason that we care about it is that
there are worse case to average case
reductions for lwe there are both
classical and quantum ones although the
classical reductions have some worse
parameters but
the reductions still do exist
and so now you know lwe is fundamentally
an average case problem
so now to show how average case
startness of lwe it's devices to show
worst-case hardness to certain lattice
problems
you can also build lots of cryptographic
primitives from learning with errors
such as one-way functions public key
encryption and lots lots more and in
fact these are secure in a post quantum
setting as well
and you can in fact even build a quantum
cryptography so like not just in a post
quantum world but truly quantum
cryptography assuming the hardness of
lwe such as a classically verifying
quantum computation and producing
certifiable randomness from an untrusted
quantum source
okay
let me switch gears a bit and talk about
the continuous variance of lwe defined
by bruna
regev song and tank
so on the left is just uh i've
reproduced what i've said about lwe just
so you can compare
so for clwe
let s to the n minus 1 denote the unit
sphere in r n so just the set of all
unit vectors
in a dimension n
which you can think of as an n minus 1
dimensional sphere
so our secret is going to be sampled
uniformly at random from this unit
sphere
each sample is now going to be drawn
from a multivariate gaussian
where the mean is the all zeros vector
in r to the n
and the covariance matrix is the
identity
and another way to think of this
distribution
is that you have n coordinates
each of which is independently
a univariate standard gaussian
so you can think of each coordinate as
being a gaussian with mean zero and
variance one and some independent copies
of it in a in dimension
the noise is once again going to be from
a univariate gaussian i'll just give the
parameter a different name then lwe just
so we could compare the two
and once again the assumption is that if
you take these samples ai and you look
at noisy inner products
it should be computationally
indistinguishable
from a i along with a uniform random
real numbers now mod one
so let's just take a second to compare
these two
so i've certainly introduced some uh
some new parameters this beta and this
gamma
and let me try to give some intuition as
to
how to think of these parameters
so i urge you to think of beta as really
being like a noise to signal ratio
because we're taking things mod 1 and
we're adding some noise of width beta to
it so think of beta as exactly how much
noise you're you know adding to the
signal
and just an analogy with uh lwe
the noise to signal ratio in lwe is
going to be sigma over q
so i urge you to think of beta as being
roughly this quantity and later i'll
make this a little bit more precise
but certainly think of beta less than
one maybe like one over a polynomial and
n for example
but in analogy to lw we think of it as
roughly sigma over q
what about this parameter gamma
why even have a parameter gamma there
isn't really a parameter gamma in lwe
the point is a little bit of a syntactic
one
which is that in clwe
our secret here is a unit vector
whereas in lwe it's certainly not it's
drawn uniformly at random from zq to the
n
so you could think of gamma as really
absorbing the norm like the magnitude of
the norm
of uh the secret vector
and certainly in dimension and think of
it as being at least at least root n
okay so now just to get a little bit of
a geometric understanding
of what clwe is
so here i've plotted uh clw some clw
samples in uh
in dimension two
so in the x y plane
we're going to have samples from a two
dimensional standard gaussian
and uh the color
is represented by uh the second
component of the clwb samples these are
noisy inner products
so there and you know mod 1 is indicated
by the color and the in the bar here
in this case the secret vector is a
straight up and to the right
and one thing you might notice is that
you know you have bands of the same
color roughly in perpendicular slices to
the secret vector s
and the reason for that is that these
second components really only care about
your projection onto this vector s
so that's why you see the structure of
like hyper planes you know in this case
uh like lines in dimension two
perpendicular to the secret s
are there any questions about this uh
distribution
i'll certainly be talking about this a
lot so
okay
because it's just my bad intuition about
continuous things so is there a regime
where it's clear that the problem is
statistically hard like with rwe if i
don't have enough samples that is
statistically hard can you say something
analogous here
yeah probably like similar to low
samples that should be hard
uh certainly if your noise is really big
it'll be
hard
can you repeat always the reason for the
gamma parameter
oh yeah okay so the point of gamma is
that it uh
and although there is uh the secret is
might have arbitrary norm it'll be like
at least n maybe like cube of that
roughly
but in clwe our secret vector is drawn
from the unit sphere so it always says
norm one
so you could think of gamma as
essentially like taking uh account for
the fact that in lw you know there's
some norm
that uh that's being hidden here because
the secret isn't effective
[Music]
yeah you could totally think of this
instead of saying the secret is from
some fixed following a given radius
instead of having a unit sphere and then
so i'm just pattern matching here but
you said gamma should be larger than
square root n and uh uh in regards
reduction somehow sigma is supposed to
be greater than square root n and i'm
just guessing that those are probably
the same thing except if it's actually
true or not
let me think
well certainly the root engine comes
from the fact that like we're in
dimension ends so things definitely
build two or more n if you have non-zero
coordinates
if you mean in terms of the reductions
from like yeah so i think that like damn
equals meaning like s is actually
sampled from like a
standard gaussian as opposed to
yeah but that's all you think of it and
this will come up later but imagine lw
where the secrets are drawn from binary
distribution in that case you know the
secrets really have norm
uh roughly your done or exactly
redundant depending on your setting and
so that's one way to think of this as
well so why is it important to make the
separate has larger norm square root of
a norm because you want to see one two
the other is more than one i don't know
how to compare these things
well i guess
so just in comparison you could
certainly divide by two here
uh and now we're really just
comparing things um sort of apples to
apples but if the gamma right here is uh
is like one so this probably becomes
actually easy
it turns out there's a there's a problem
there's an algorithm for this problem
running in time two to the gamma squared
roughly maybe it's from some polyamide
factors or logs somewhere that's very
analogous with all the viewers
yeah
exactly
but somehow gamma is like sigma and data
is somehow like sigma over q
[Music]
so yeah no we're saying that you can
think of sigma as really being the
scanner because the best algorithms are
to the second square here it's to the
gamma squared like maybe that's one way
to think of this
so sure i mean sigma and beta are
clearly anomalous
but uh yeah and
like the norm of the norm of the secret
that's exactly what it is
yeah but somehow this pattern matching
is like remarkably
sorry somehow pattern matching gamma
with sigma is like is like a remarkably
successful way to
but certainly you know
it's not like a 100 clean mapping so
maybe there's some settings where you
can get sigma uh
yeah so in fact certainly if it is zero
this is actually solvable with uh ll and
even if it's exponentially small it's
also you can use
and your samples are from a gaussian
distribution
yes sorry yeah so that part seems to be
less important and that's crucial maybe
still important but
i see some bigger differences the ais
sure you know you know just speaking out
you know we get a reduction between the
two problems so you're right yeah they
aren't too different
why can't you divide the second
component entirely by gamma
right uh and that would really sort of
seem to make things uh you know like a
one parameter which is
yeah the error will divide by gamma but
the point is that the the mod one will
become mod one over gamma as well so
gamma somehow relates to the most
significant bits the q or the mod one
here
uh whereas the beta weights to the least
significant bits which is uh the analog
analogous thing is signal
uh you could make up one yeah i don't
think it's been defined but certainly
it's uh
one thing we know is that there's a
quantum reduction from worst-case status
problems for gamma at least true down
and one might say okay great but you
know for lwe we also know a classical
reduction so you know what's the
advantage of looking at uh this problem
clwe over lwe
you know fair enough fine
from uh from clwe we actually know how
to build a public key encryption
um but you know once again like from lw
we know how to build lots more
cryptography so so you know what's
really the point of clwe like why i
introdu why you give this definition at
all
the main point that i'll try to convey
through the rest of this talk is that
clwe has connections to natural problems
in statistical learning or machine
learning
and i'll give some examples of this
figure out but this is really the reason
why clwe
is fundamentally an interesting problem
and in my opinion
and some of you may be familiar with
problems like planted clique and the
whole web of reductions that exist from
planted clique to various other problems
in high dimensional statistics
one can ask maybe does the same thing
hold for clwe
and i'll try to give some like very
beginnings of a possible
set of reductions between problems and
statistics and clwb
i should say before moving on that we do
know some uh some learning hardness from
lwe but sort of that's in the boolean
setting and i urge you to think of the
clwe type
uh statements as being much more
naturally close to problems you'd
consider in machine learning or high
dimensional statistics
okay so let me talk about the first
example
first example is that clwe implies
hardness of learning a single periodic
neuron
a neuron here in the sense of neural
network and periodic here because of the
activation function we consider is going
to be a periodic function
so in general you know it's known that
it's np hard to learn neural networks in
the worst case
but sort of in learning tasks you really
want to average case statements you know
your input probably comes from some
distribution
and you'd want to argue average average
case hardness for these problems
so let me give some one example problem
suppose we have some function f of x
which is going to be the inner product
of some secret with x and then apply uh
cosine to it with some scaling
or your inputs are not from some
distribution
they're from the multivariate gas and so
this is really an average case problem
now
and in fact the function is average case
two we define this secret from a unit
sphere in rn
the point is that this is actually a
very simple neural network right here
why is it a neural network
it's a neural network because you take
your input x you apply some linear
function to it namely the inner product
with s
and then you apply some non-linear
activation function to it in this place
in this case cosine of you know some
something
and nonetheless even for this very
simple neural network
there's a reduction from clwe to
learning noisy samples from this neural
network
in other words the clwe assumption
implies that it's hard to learn
functions given noisy samples noisy
labeled samples
in fact you know the reduction is uh
straightforward enough that i can
hopefully fit it in the rest of the rest
of this slide
the proof is a direct reduction from
clwe where you apply cosine to the
second components
so what happens
you take cosine of 2 pi times this noisy
inner product mod 1
and a few things happen
the first thing that happens is that
this mod 1
now completely goes away
because that just corresponds to adding
integer multiples of 2 pi to cosine
which has no effect on the cosine
and the second is that you know we can
bring out our noise ei into some
different noise ei prime that's going to
be not too much bigger than ei
just because cosine is nice and lip
shits and doesn't have
a large derivative
but this is exactly a noisy sample from
this function f sub s
so just by applying cosine we've mapped
the problem with clwe to this learning
task from a very simple neural network
and so clwe implies hardness of learning
this neural network in an average case
setting you have average inputs and your
function is also average
okay let me move to a different example
which says that clwe can allow an
adversary to plant undetectable back
doors in certain models
and so in general in machine learning it
turns out that linear classifiers put on
top of random features or random
functions of your input data tend to be
a reasonably expressive and have some
nice properties
in other words you take your input data
you apply some random functions to them
and then you train some linear
classifier on top of these random
functions
these have some nice properties it turns
out and one set of random features that
people consider are random fourier
features
and don't worry too much about you know
the math or the exact structure of these
functions
i'm not going to refer to them later on
in the talk
but uh the important thing to note is
that these random functions
are defined by the randomness given by
uh this wi here
and this phase bi
this wi is from a standard gaussian and
the bi is some phase
it turns out that for assuming the
hardness of clwe
an adversary can undetectably
change the distribution of wi
and as a result of that change it can
plant backdoors in the model
and what do i mean by a back door in the
model i mean that the uh if you let the
adversary train your model
uh if you replace this uh wi with some
backdoor randomness the adversary can
give you labeled examples with like
flipped classifications for example with
only a small perturbation in the input
and just for the sake of time i'm not
going to you know get into the proof of
how this is done but it's just you know
changing the randomness of wi to
something that is indistinguishable
computationally assuming the hardness of
clwb
let me move to my last example
and the one i want to focus most on
is that clwe implies hardness of
learning mixtures of gaussians
and so what do i mean by a mixture of
gaussians
so in general a mixture of gaussians is
a distribution d
whose density function
can be written as a convex combination
of multivariate gaussian distributions
you could equivalently think of this as
saying with you know every time you want
to take a sample from d
with probability w i
you choose component i
and once you choose component i you
sample from multivariate gaussian
with mean mu i
and covariance matrix sigma i
just get some pictorial like intuition
in like what dimension one you could
think of a density function of a mixture
looking like this
like the blue densities are the
densities of each component say weighted
and the red is the overall combination
of these density functions
and mixtures of gaussians are sort of a
natural way to model things in science
in nature and certainly in machine
learning
and the natural task
is given samples from such a
distribution
try to estimate all the parameters of
this mixture of gaussians in other words
given sample access so this distribution
d
estimate w i mu i
and sigma i for all i
that's a natural task
it turns out one can even define a
weaker goal
called density estimation
which is essentially an improper
learning version of this
which says give an amp sample access
output some distribution it doesn't have
to be a mixture of gaussians but some
distribution that approximates the
mixture of gaussians
and you output the distribution in terms
of a density function
so you output some candidate density
function that's going to look close to
the original density function that's the
mixture of gaussians
and why do i say this is a weaker goal
i say it's a weaker goal
because certainly if you can estimate
the parameters
you can plug in those parameters and
that instantly gives you a candidate
density function
and it's in fact weaker in a stronger
sense
in that uh there are information
theoretic separations between these two
tasks in terms of sample complexity
okay
so how does this how is this all related
to clwe
it turns out that clwe implies hardness
of learning mixtures of gaussians
even this easier task of a density
estimation
let me try to you know give some
intuition for why this is true
so on the left here you know we have our
clwe plot from before
let's say my favorite color is red and i
want to look only at the the red samples
here
we'll get something that looks roughly
like this
uh this distribution has a name it's
called the homogeneous clwe distribution
that's called the homogeneous version
because i'm conditioning the samples ai
on the fact that the noisy inner
products are zero mod one
because you know the color being red
exactly means that mod one the second
component is zero
and so if you uh you know condition your
samples based on that condition you're
going to get exactly a picture like this
and just to get a sense of some of the
geometry here
the separation between each of these
slices or each of these pancakes sort of
in higher dimension
there's going to be a roughly one over
gamma gap between
each of these slices
and the width of each of these
you know bands in itself is roughly beta
over gamma
the main point here is that this itself
is a mixture of gaussian distributions
like each of these little slices is a
gaussian distribution
or your covariance matrix is squashed in
the direction of the secret vector
and the means are going to be equally
spaced out
on the line generated by the secret
vector s
so each of these little components here
is itself a gaussian distribution
and another point i want to make here is
uh how many components are there in this
gaussian distribution in the in this
gaussian mixture
well because of the gap between
each of these gaussian pancakes is
roughly one over gamma and because most
of the mass of a gaussian is sort of
contained very close to
the origin they're going to be roughly
of gamma components uh that can you know
that contains almost all of your mass of
the gaussian so think of this as a
as a mixture of gaussians with roughly
gamma components
and uh just to you know talk a little
bit more formally the decisional
hclw problem or homogeneous clwe problem
is to distinguish this distribution here
from just a standard gaussian
and to you maybe that sounds like an
easy problem like well you know there
there's there are stripes here clearly
standard gaussian doesn't you know why
is this a hard problem
distribution again
sure so uh you can think of it as a
conditioning
the clw distribution on the second
component being 0
0
it's like roughly gamma times the inner
product of the sample with s
is going to be an integer roughly
and indeed we'll see that there's a
reduction between
clwe and the homogeneous version of clw
by rejection sampling
right so that is the decision of the
decision problem is just to distinguish
this from one standard galaxy converted
from a standard from state and from
samples from a standard
and why is this hard
okay so one of these is a standard
gaussian one of them is hclwe
can any of you all tell me which is
which
exactly the left one is hclwe because
for a split second in time there you can
see the discrete structure of uh hclwb
whereas in yes exactly or as in the
standard gaussian
it you know there's no discrete
structure at all
so the point is you have to look exactly
at the right direction to notice this
discreteness
and especially in higher dimension when
they're exponentially many directions
you can have to look at you know how do
you find the right one that lets you see
this discrete structure
that's the intuition as to why this
problem is hard
just going back to clwe
as i alluded to earlier there's a
reduction
from clwe to hclwe
just by rejection sampling carefully
you know you take components you look at
the second component
if it's close to zero mod one you keep
it with some probability and if you
reason about this in the right way you
get a reduction
and because the homogeneous clwe
distribution is itself a mixture of
gaussians
there's a reduction from this decision
problem hclwe
to even density estimation it turns out
for mixtures of gaussians
so what does the second statement mean
i'm just saying if you have an algorithm
that gives you a density estimate for
mixtures of gaussians
you can use such an algorithm
to distinguish between the homogeneous
cwe distribution and the standard uh
gaussian distribution
in other words you can perform some
statistical tests on this density
estimate that you get
that allows you to distinguish between
these two cases
and combining these two facts just
directly composing these reductions
we have a reduction from clwe to
learning mixtures of gaussians
and i just want to highlight again that
the number of gaussian components is
going to be roughly roughly of gamma
and gamma as i sort of alluded to in the
beginning of the talk you should think
of it as the norm of the secret vector
so roughly the number of components in
your mixture is roughly going to be the
norm of your secret vector that you
start with
just for the sake of intuition
okay so let's uh let's take a little bit
of a step back
in comparing lwe and clwe
so we know that lwe is hard under even
classical worst-case labs assumptions
and you can build lots of cryptography
from lwb
clwe we know it's hard under quantum
worst-case slash assumptions in other
words there's a quantum reduction
and uh i've just shown some examples
that clwe has natural connections the
problem
in statistics and machine learning
someone can ask you know can we show uh
classical reduction from worst case
lotus problems to clwe
or you know more generally lwe has been
studied for a while now can we
generically
apply results we know from lwe like
tools or hardness and we generically
port them over to clwv
the answer to both these questions we
show is yes
specifically we show a classical
reduction
from worst-case lattice problems to clwv
and we do this by first using the fact
that there's a classical reduction from
worst-case problems to lwe
and then by giving a classical reduction
from lwe to clb
and composing these two gives a
classical reduction from worst-case
status problems to clw
okay how do we show a classical
reduction from lwe to clwe
the first main step
as i alluded to a little bit earlier
is that we use secret key leakage
resilience results for lwe to reduce to
a binary secret version of lwe with some
slight increase in the dimension and
some other loss and parameters
so we first do that
and then we show that if you start with
lwe
where all of your secrets have some
fixed and ideally small norm
r
then you can reduce lwe to clwe
with the following parameter
dependencies
so this gamma parameter in crwe will be
roughly the norm
of the lwe secrets that you started with
this sort of justifies what i mentioned
earlier you know when i defined clwe
and also this beta parameter
is uh up to constant factors going to
exactly be the
inverse of the signal to noise ratio in
lwe
it's going to be roughly sigma over q
and combining you know m1 and theorem 2
gives you a full reduction from lwe to
clwb
we also show how to apply our results
for hardness or to get more hardness
results for learning mixtures of
gaussians
so the original paper defining clwe
shows that under quantum worst case
hardness of lattice problems
you get hardness for learning roughly
root n gaussian components in your
mixture
and you know why is there this root n
here
because root n is here because uh brst
give the reduction from quantum you know
give the quantum reduction
from worst case lattice problems to clwe
only for gamma being at least root n
and because gamma as i said is the
number of gaussian components
uh in your mixture they get stuck at
this uh this root n factor
we show under polynomial hardness of lwe
how to bring this down to n to the
epsilon
for any positive epsilon
and if we want to stretch parameters a
little bit
under sub-exponential setting of lwe we
show how to get log of n to the one plus
epsilon hardness for gaussian for
uh learning gaussian fixtures
so just to state what i mean here
i'm saying under this assumption on the
in the middle column
there's no algorithm in polynomial time
that can learn mixtures of gaussians
that can handle the following a number
of gaussian components in the mixture
so we went all the way from root n to
log events epsilon but you know
admittedly under uh quantitatively
stronger assumptions but assumptions
that i imagine most of us probably
believe
uh
right yes they do so the main parameter
here that allows us to get these
flexible results is the fact that we
play with this parameter gain
so this gamma is going to roughly tell
you that we're gassing components and so
the primary gamma is going to tell you
like what the how spread out the
gaussians are and you know how wide each
of the gaussians are because we also do
see they do look a little bit different
but they're all going to be gaussian uh
pancake distributions
change
oh oh without the question
calcium has a
solid deviation yeah
they don't really yeah that's the thing
they don't really change
i mean yeah they change in scale but
they don't the the general structure is
that you have to have some thinkings
um but the quantitative like how far
apart they are from each other and how
wide they are
so
far apart there's new insigma which is
there
so mu is just the the mean of the
distribution the means are going to be
uh like equally spaced out they're going
to be on the line generated by s states
that y roughly one over gamma
but with the you know the covariance and
the
the direction's going to be roughly
better to get up and so beta and gamma
certainly change so the quantitative
covariance matrix is going to change
that's true
becomes further apart right
gamma gets smaller
so they get further apart
which
potentially becomes an even easier
problem
but it doesn't but you know it's still
hard
but data stays fixed
and gets wider oh yes okay so you're
spreading you're spreading out your
pancakes more but each pancake
okay so what i mean look at us you know
this is a table of hardness
like what are the actual algorithms for
this problem
this problem has really been studied a
lot in statistics and machine learning
and so you can ask okay you know in
polynomial time
how many gaps and components
can you learn in your mixture
it turns out you know there's been a lot
of work on it but still you know the
best algorithms that work in general can
only handle a constant number
of gaussian components in polynomial
time
so if you view things in a complexity
theoretic perspective
you know you believe sub exponential lwe
you can say okay you know
there's this uh gap between constant and
log of n to the one plus epsilon you
know where is the true you know what's
the what's the truth you know how many
gaussian components can you truly learn
in polynomial time
and this is a this is an open question
you can also oh yeah
so that's actually the direction i'm
showing you
yeah so uh
this table was saying if you can solve
uh yes you can you can solve a density
estimation for making gaussians that can
handle this many gaussian components
then you can uh break polynomial or
exponential
so
this reduction is tight enough that you
can say something working free
beyond polynomial time like
if you make an assumption about the best
algorithm for continuous lwe
okay
uh
just make sure i
understand say that the best algorithm
is the true to the gamma square
algorithm for
yourself
can you translate that to a actual lower
time
running time lower bound for
for learning mixtures of reactions
i guess how does that differ from yeah
because now you just stay putting it on
the other side
so i'd like to get a concrete like
algorithmic hardness lower bound
and there's some appropriate assumptions
for continuous on the video for lwe
right so
because we have like cryptanalysis of
lwe for example that gives us
actual concrete overbound in our
exponential the hardness of lwe is and
maybe we can translate those
to uh to learning
i see yeah i guess the question of like
does an algorithm for lw imply an
algorithm for this you know what i'm not
so sure in terms of concrete
yeah that's not the question yeah
like i'll conclude that so if you have a
concrete statement of the reduction
that is tight enough in terms of running
time that allows you really to mix to
give a more fine-grained state
yeah yeah i think
i think the reduction is reasonably
tight in terms of like there's some
additive polynomial factors certainly
but uh
that shouldn't be too too crazy but yeah
i think it depends exactly what sort of
fine-grained setting uh
and so so you know i mentioned a
complexity theoretic way of interpreting
better results an algorithmic way to
interpret the result to say you know
maybe you're
even though these uh statistics problems
have been studied for a long time maybe
you think there's a some sub-exponential
time algorithm for learning mixtures of
gaussians specifically sub-exponential
and the number of gas components g
if such an algorithm exists that gives
you a sub-exponential time algorithm for
lwe and certainly that's a
w very striking consequence to i've seen
many of us in this room
complexity and then
reduction running time and these things
translate
yeah so it gets a little bit messy to
like quantify everything but um the
running time
is uh
so the
so certainly for the galaxy mixtures you
know you're running time and polynomial
sample complexity
um
and that gets you uh depending on the
various settings either you know
sub-exponential or polynomial sample
complexity for lwb
so the exponential of w is the possible
exponential samples also yes yes
so now let me give a
sort of general uh overview of how we
reduce uh lwe to clwe
and i really claim you know it's not
it's not a complicated proof it's a
relatively simple proof and
hopefully i can convince you of uh the
reduction in in the remaining time that
we have
so the first step is going to be as i
said before we're going to reduce a
uniform secret over z q to the l let's
say in dimension l
to a binary secret s in dimension n
where n is a little bit bigger than l
and this uses uh existing uh secret key
leakage resilience results for lw
but actually i'm going to make this
reduction a little bit more general
i'm actually going to work with a k
sparse secrets s
what do i mean i mean uh sparse secrets
where they're exactly k non-zero entries
and they're plus or minus 1.
so you could set k here to be n and
that's exactly binary secrets with a
plus or minus one meaning binary here
and you might ask what's the point of
doing this what's the gain
the point here is that the sparsity
lets us claim that the norm of these
secrets are exactly square root of k
and the point is we can tune this
parameter k however we like
uh to get you the l two norm of the
secret uh however small you want it to
be as long as you preserve entropy
effectively
and uh the sparsity is going to come in
a number of places in our in our
reduction
one you know it fixes the norm but two
is the fact that the norm is small
and this gives you both like a small
error blow up
but most crucially for our learning
gaussians result
the norm of the secret is going to
become the number of gaston components
roughly
so this is what lets us state hardness
for a small number of gaussian
components
what we do this is we adopt existing
hardness results for binary secrets and
just adapt them to the case bar setting
next we're going to reduce a discrete
uniform
samples to continuous uniform sounds
and this is a simple enough as adding
noise to smooth out the samples
but you know there's a little bit of a
nuance here that i'll get to shortly
and it turns out the you know the blow
up and the noise here in this reduction
is going to be small because the l2 norm
of the secret is small
next we're going to convert these
continuous uniform samples ai to
continuous gaussian ai
and you know might as well normalize
things and divide by q
and uh just to syntactically match with
clwe we can make the unit vector we can
make the secret a unit vector and move
the magnitude of the secret into gamma
and uh so that's give that tells us that
beta you know we divide by q to get
roughly sigma over q
and gamma is going to be the thing that
takes all the norm from our secret which
we said was root k because of sparsity
so once again using sparsity we've
gotten the fact that gamma can be as
small as root k
like in brst they show hardness for only
root n gamma here we say okay we can get
smaller by reducing k
the way we show this is we
take inspiration from uh blmr
and we show a
gaussian pre-image sampling llama
that says given something that's uniform
mod one s a i over q
we can sample a pre image a tilde i
such that uh the marginal distribution
of a tilde i is going to be gaussian
continuous gaussian
and mod 1 it's going to be equivalent to
the given a i over q
it turns out that the dislema exactly
allows you to reduce a uniform samples
mod q to
continuous gaussian samples
and lastly just to fully bring us back
to the setting of clwe
we effectively renormalize the secret
distribution
from case farce unit norm secrets to
completely random unit vector secrets in
rn
and the way to do this is we apply a
random rotation matrix to the samples
so for each ai you just apply a random r
times a i
and this does the effect of now making
the secret
um r times s where r is a random
rotation
and because the random rotation now r
times s is going to be a uniformly
random secret vector
all right sorry uniformly random unit
vector
so this is the this is the full
reduction going from lwe to clwb
i'll talk a little bit in more detail
about uh the second step
this is an example to get a flavor of
sort of what's going on
so in the second step
we reduce a discrete uniform ai
to a continuous uniform ai prime let's
say
how do we do this
i said we're just going to add gaussian
noise to all the samples
so think of think of alpha here as being
a small like certainly less than q
what we're going to do as i said is
we're going to add this gaussian noise
equal to i to the samples
and now you can view this uh
you know this tuple in terms of the
sample a i prime
which is the sum of a i
and this gaussian noise e tilde i
but this has the effect that we have to
readjust our secret
uh to somehow you know incorporate this
uh added term we have to take care of
or in other words you can write the
sample like this
you can write it in terms of a new
sample a i prime
which is a i plus equals i mod q
and uh this error e i prime has to be
adjusted to handle the fact that we've
changed from ai to ai prime
so first we have to show that you know
this ai prime this distribution is now a
continuous uniform as opposed to uh you
know given that a i is discrete uniform
and e tilde i is a continuous gaussian
and this holds by like standard uh by
standard uh smoothing on the techniques
of michonne show and regive
and now this step is a little bit more
subtle but
even given this a i prime
we have to show that the conditional
distribution on e i prime
is going to be close to a gaussian
distribution
indeed this holds uh by standard like
convolution lemmas for discrete
gaussians
but the point here i want to point out
is that uh the noise blow up here
depends on the l2 norm of the secret
so once again relying on the fact that
the l2 norm of the secret is both fixed
and small allows us to do its reduction
without too much noise blow up
and this concludes the technical portion
of the talk and this concludes step two
just move to some open questions
tightness of reductions
but really it's it's really really about
the and this really
yeah it's certainly uh
certainly between a fixed norm version
of lwe
and uh crwe
we show pretty tight reductions between
the two
up to some small uh
small thing and we're in uh
yeah that we have a reduction from uh
clw to lw but there's a small gap in
that we can't show it all the way from
complete unit vector sequence the
uniform unit vector secrets we can only
do it from some discrete
set of students
but after that you know the reduction
between the two are reasonably tight
okay so just to conclude with some open
questions one is uh can we decrease the
number of gaussian components that we
show in hardness for
so i say that it's hard for the log
events of the oneplus epsilon gaussian
components you know can you bring this
all the way down to even constant
or a super constant really
and uh you know ideally would like
cryptographic hardness
but more generally like our lattice is
really the right place to look
to get these hardness results for
learning mixtures of gaussians
another question is you know can you
build like new or better cryptography
from clwe as opposed to lwe
and you might instantly complain and say
wait a minute we've just shown a
reduction from lwe to clwe
so if you base any cryptography off clwe
you might as well base it off lwe as
well
but the point you know that's
technically true
but the point is maybe clwe gives you a
different starting point
with these distributions that allows you
to you know think of something that you
might not have thought of if you started
directly from lwe
and lastly you know i gave some examples
of connections to other problems in high
dimensional statistics
are there other natural connections are
there other examples that could have
added to this list
and certainly you know i think the
answer is yes
i think the question is just what are
they and what do these connections look
like
you know maybe an analogy uh with uh
planted clique you know with planted
clique there are lots of connections to
other uh problems in high dimensional
statistics is the same true for clwe
you know i don't know but i think it's
certainly an interesting question to
look at
all right thanks so much
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i mean yeah right you can ask the
question exactly the satellite can you
reduce all wb directly to mixtures of
gasolines
certainly maybe i do think clwe's a
completely reasonable middle ground
because what is cll really doing it's
really making the samples go from
discrete uniform to gaussian
if you get some mixtures of gaussian you
have to go to guessing somehow so that
seems like a very natural way to do it
well in terms of secret vector uh you
know secret directions you know maybe
the unit sphere isn't the right thing
you know i'm not sure
maybe uh the secret doesn't come from a
unisphere maybe the norm is not fixed
you know can you show around this well
you know maybe yeah i don't know
the relationship
against dictated by the number of
symbols so it's natural like you know i
i i guess if i were to try to reduce
from lwe to mixtures learning mixtures
i would go through these steps basically
and you know
why not abstract it out you know
so you think it's useful
i'm a bit confused by the problem itself
like so you you have a reduction from
clwe to lwe
what is the model of computation you're
considering because like on the one hand
you have
you you seem to be able to under real so
i suppose that you're on the real run on
the other hand you have the lw frame
which is supposedly handled in the
integer integer round model so how do
you like bridge between the two because
like like real run is infinitely more
powerful than integer ram
so how
i mean
everything is i mean the reduction
points only in the real-world model i
guess and so so no no i mean whenever we
say continuous really think about it as
you know on a grid essentially not
really continuous without a trade with
arbitrary polynomial transition so
because
so you handle the the continuous library
as already discretized from the
beginning
only yes formally when you do the
reductions but so in that case if you're
discretized over the taurus isn't it
already a variant of lw itself so what
is the difference between clwe and let's
say discretized clwe at the fine grain
scale
the distribution is different first of
all
the distribution of a is rather than
coming from q uh this comes from a
gaussian right so that's uh okay
that's that's that's a big difference
right okay okay so so
which i find it will be useful to
describe the skilled up version of clwe
so so somehow you know
i think of uh sort of this
discretization as a
distraction really
you know you have to deal with it when
you write down a formal reduction really
it's so much cleaner to think about just
the continuous version mathematically
it's so much cleaner
you know discretization is painful then
yeah yeah why do it you know we want to
live in a clean useful world why do it
yeah you have to do it to write a paper
but i want what you have to do is to go
back to a degree right
yeah i mean like even when you say even
when you write oh it's interesting
because we could build crypts on it but
uh i mean at one point if you just want
to have a real crypto system it would be
discretized so it would be that's right
that's right so then you have to deal
with this uh okay
well i still find it'll be useful to
have it still that
version i guess you describe those
distributions in uh larger domains
i'm sure
you think that in the spirit of the
previous question i think there are like
other distributions
that you could
get equivalences between like okay now
you have one lw distribution uniform
over zq you have another one which is
this gaussian distribution are there
others
probably uh i think one another their
reduction is instead of going from
discrete to uniform
like discrete uh uniform to continuous
uniform and then continuous uniformity
continuous casting you can probably go
to this recalculate instead like
discreet uniform to discrete acid and
then it's freaked out so it gets cancer
that's probably a very other natural way
to do it
um in terms of things besides that i
think it'll be very interesting
that's not like sort of completely
different looking uh distributions but i
mean like you know that there's some
worst-case average case reductions for
the secret distribution for example for
outside and also for community just be a
little bit careful but uh
sorry for the samples i think it's an
interesting option in this context you
have l infinity and l2 so the natural
stick to try is l1
as long as your distribution is has
enough entropy right it's not too weird
uh you should you should you should be
right that's definitely true for s and
maybe it's also true for a somehow right
it should be true yeah
so you're saying that the only
constraint on the distribution of a
should be the entropy there is no
niceness appropriately defined so
is
just for the sharpness
for the discussions
all right thanks everyone thanks to all
the speakers for the for the fun
workshop